now Spice Girls can you tell us yeah
okay here we
go we waited for the information she
couldn't talk about it before but now
she can there's five of us and we're
doing something together all five like
in 2019 it was four now it's five what
why didn't wasn't it Victoria that was
didn't want she didn't want it but now
it wasn't a case if she didn't want her
she just wanted to do something else her
fashion show was pop poing off not
literally popping off her fashion show
fashion stuff was like going crazy it's
still going crazy people like she has a
a successful fashion very successful she
wanted focus on that and now she didn't
want to necessarily be up on stage are
you writing new
music is that what you're not allowed to
talk about there's lots of things I
can't talk about you interrupt you
always interrupt and don't let them
things that you can't talk she wasn't
going to answer that well she was her
eyes were opening but there's lots of
stuff and we're going to do
it can you be a little more vague uh
what what is your favorite of all the
ones we know what is your favorite Spice
Girl song oh they're all my favorite
because we wrote them all to be honest
did you have equal writing because I I
watched that that documentary on the
Beatles And I watched how they did it
and I don't there isn't a documentary
really on the process of how you guys
wrote the song
not that
one
no it's going to be good I can't talk
about I can't talk about it yet we're
not allowed to talk about it yet but
there so much but it's going to it's
going to be going to be like who
[Music]
he